if you just finished watching The
Witcher on Netflix you are probably
getting the urge to replay The Witcher 3
right about now but I'm here to say hold
your OSHA's there buddy before you start
a new game in The Witcher 3 you better
play it the right way now you're
probably thinking to yourself who is
this guy
why is what is there even a correct way
to play The Witcher 3 well yes there is
and I'm glad you asked and you should
listen to me because I haven't stopped
playing The Witcher 3 since 2015 I've
seen all the outcomes I've played all
the quests I've read all the books I've
read the graphic novels and I even know
how to pronounce said they project
correctly and yes I've seen both of the
TV shows and let me tell you one is much
better than the other
get ready nerds because it's time to
read a book eight in fact I only have
two at my desk the rest are at home I
swear but this one's in Portuguese
that's right we're starting from the
very beginning right now you're probably
thinking I just want to slay some
monsters and get intimate with some
sorceress but trust me when I say you
need to be patient the next few weeks
the only thing you're gonna get intimate
with are words on a page to get the most
out of The Witcher 3 you have to make
sure you know everything from the
locations to the actually you know what
let's back it up a little bit before you
do anything you should probably study a
map of the continent yes it's called the
continent I don't know why who cares
just follow along anyway before you
crack open some of those tomes take a
good hard look at the world you'll be
inhabiting for the next oh I don't know
500 hours or so if you don't know the
difference between a turn or Angra and
sintra or Lyria you're going to need to
rectify that all right back to the books
as I was saying to get the most out of
The Witcher 3 you want to know all of
the side characters all of the locations
and everyone's back story you'll get
answers to questions like what happened
to the sorcerers why does Dijkstra limp
how did ciri end up under Geralt Swing
and what keeps Geralt in yen together
despite everything I could go on and on
but I think you get the picture to its
credit The Witcher 3 is an easy game to
enjoy even without all that background
however it's important to remember that
the games aren't
telling of the books or a soft reboot
rather the games pick up right where the
novels end with that out of the way it's
time to start reading you want to start
with the two collections of short
stories the last wish and the sort of
destiny
most of these follow the exploits of
Geralt in his younger years and depict
how he met characters like ciri yen and
dandelion after that it's on to the
novels I shouldn't tell you he ordered
to read these in since you know they're
numbered but here goes blood of elves
time of contempt baptism by fire the
Tower of swallows and the Lady of the
lake look that's a lot of reading and
I'd like to congratulate you because
you're a fast reader but we aren't done
yet there's still one more novel we
haven't discussed called season of
storms but I'm gonna cut you a break and
call this optional reading well it's
well worth the read it makes most sense
to read this last even though it takes
place before the main anthology okay
okay okay
now hold on before you call me an
elitist and click out of this video just
hear me out how long have you been
reading these books for weeks months
even ideally you would have been so
engrossed in the books that you've spent
all your free time those down in the
text you haven't gone out with any
friends you haven't bought any expensive
video games and you cancelled your 47
different subscription services if I've
done the math correctly which I have
because I was a liberal arts major then
you should have the right amount of
money saved for a gaming PC excellent
now let's build this mother effort
[Music]
okay now that we've spent a lot of time
and money on a gaming PC let's clear the
air a little bit all right witcher 2
which her technically technically you
could play this game on an xbox one ps4
or the little console that could the
nintendo switch it's still a fantastic
game wherever you choose to play it but
let's stop and think for a minute now
why would i want you to build a pc if
you can play a damn good version of the
witcher 3 on a console there's no such
thing as a perfect playthrough of the
witcher 3 if you haven't played one
which you can only play on pc and -
after all your decisions do carry over
to 3 simulating a witcher 2 save is for
casuals
fortunately the witcher 1 and 2 are
considerably shorter than the witcher 3
the two should set you back around 60 to
70 hours depending on how much of a
completionist you are once you roll
credits in the witcher 2 you are ready
[Music]
I'm just kidding
now you really think I'd make you go
through all the trouble of building a PC
and not recommend some kickass mods you
must be on a fist tech bender or
something now I'll be the first to admit
that most of the Witcher 3 mods are a
bit underwhelming now I don't mean that
in a bad way
I just want to rein in your expectations
a bit most of the mods I'm about to
recommend our quality of life mods and
while they seem small they can make a
huge difference so here's how this is
gonna work
first I'm gonna list off a couple mods
that I think are absolutely essential
and then highlight a few mods that I
like to use when I play The Witcher 3
the first mod I want to highlight that
is absolutely necessary is wasteland
ghost friendly HUD mod this gives you
way more options when customizing the UI
we'll get back to why that's so
important later the next mod worth
installing is absolute camera by P Mark
which well lets you tweak the camera
with a few simple changes you can make
the witcher 3 all the more cinematic
finally some other mods I typically use
are the super turbo lighting mod from
ascend fee ascend T or something I think
and if your machine is up for it the
witcher HD reworked project by hulk
hogan no not the hulk hogan you're
probably thinking of while you're at it
you'll probably need the script merger
by another symbiote basically this
program will fix anything you will
undoubtedly [ __ ] up in the game's code
and occasionally it won't be able to fix
it either so you'll probably have to
uninstall a few mods
[Music]
now finally without further ado you can
fire
well actually wait hold on there's one
more thing we have to do first right
click on the Witcher 3 and steam click
on properties and then navigate to
language click the drop down menu and
select polish that's right if we're
gonna play The Witcher 3 we're not gonna
play it in English we're gonna play it
in its native tongue
make sure subtitles are turned on unless
you know you know polish monsters don't
over use any I'm way up on the gnome
next let's crank up the difficulty
regardless of whether you're starting a
new game or doing a new game+ in The
Witcher 3 you owe it to yourself to make
it hurt a little do you think Henry
Cavill got that ripped by playing uneasy
look I know that for many of us the
combat isn't the highlight of these
games but still if monster hunting is a
hard life for Geralt it's got to be a
hard one for you sure you're here for
that good good story but I encourage you
to push yourself especially if you've
already played The Witcher 3 by
increasing the difficulty you'll have to
read up on monsters in the bestiary
prepare oils and potions and use your
signs more strategically the extra
challenge is good but what this really
does is well it makes you feel even more
like a Witcher in a dangerous world
finally let's turn off that HUD 5 years
later and The Witcher 3 is still a
beautiful game so let's bask in some of
that beauty now turning off the HUD does
pose us with quite a few problems how
will I know where I'm going how will I
know how much health I have how will I
know which potions I have equipped fear
not young Witcher remember that mod I
had you install called friendly HUD that
mod lets you do a number of nifty things
like show your health when you get hit
or activate your mini-map when you use
your wits your vision you could arrange
this however you like but the goal is to
be less reliant on your mini-map and
hopefully use natural landmarks to guide
you around the world now as for the
actual playthrough you probably want to
know the critical path
what should you dive into and what
should you skip my simple answer is play
all of it like everything there's
there's there's everything in this game
is really good worth your time you did
all this work so why not just play
everything
so there you have it if my calculations
are correct you should be able to play
The Witcher 3 on April I mean there it
is and all of its glory you can finally
play or replay The Witcher 3 on April I
mean what else would you possibly be
doing on that day might as well
marketing your calendar
[Music]